- Welcome everybody, thank you for coming.
The professors with me on stage
are brilliant scholars in their fields
who also have a full life on Twitter,
and we're here to talk
about what that means
for their intellectual, social,
professional, and personal lives.
This introduction was
280 characters (laughs).
(audience laughs)
So there are a lot of conversations
about what academics are doing on Twitter.
This is a fairly good representation
of some of the marked media abuses,
from procrastinating, gossiping
about people in one's field,
having interactions with people
they have an intellectual crush on,
but because Twitter's been around
for a while now and academics
have been on it for a while,
there've been a lot of reactions
in the press about, and
in the scholarly press,
about whether this is good or bad.
What are the purposes, is
it, the scholar for instance
of that New York Times
op-ed, the one that went,
Quit Social Media, Your
Career May Depend on It,
said, he's a young Georgetown professor
named Cal Newport, he wrote, "The idea
"of purposefully introducing into my life
"a service designed to
fragment my attention
"is as scary to me as the idea
"of smoking would be to
an endurance athlete,
"and it should be to you if you're serious
"about creating things that matter."
Well, we have some differing opinions
among our distinguished panelists.
Teresa Chahine is doing the work
that so many of us talked about.
She is the--
And Teresa is in green here.
She is the inaugural Sheila and Ron
Marcelo Lecturer in
social entrepreneurship,
the author of Introduction
to Social Entrepreneurship,
a 12-step framework for building
impactful ventures in new
and existing organizations.
Her research focuses on developing tools
to characterize and advance social
and environmental determinants of health.
She also launched the first
social entrepreneurship
program in the context of
public health at Harvard.
She was responsible for launching
the first venture
philanthropy organization
in her home country of Lebanon,
providing tailored financial and critical
management support to social enterprises,
serving marginalized populations
through education and job
creation for youth and women.
If Alexander Hamilton had Twitter,
then he would be
retweeting Joanne Freeman.
(audience laughs)
She is professor of history
and American studies
and is a leading expert
on early American politics and culture,
the author of the
award-winning Affairs of Honor:
National Politics in the New Republic,
and editor of Alexander Hamilton: Writings
and The Essential Hamilton.
Her work informed the writing
of Broadway's Hamilton.
A co-host of the popular
American history podcast
Backstory, which I
recommend everyone download
immediately after exiting this conference,
(panelists laugh)
and a commenter on documentaries
on PBS The History Channel, she also has
an active interest in
public-minded history.
Her most recent book The Field of Blood:
Violence in Congress and
the Road to Civil War
was a New York Times notable book for 2018
and a finalist for the Lincoln Prize.
Michael Kraus, there,
holding a coffee cup,
is an exceptionally prolific scholar
and is also an exceptionally
prolific tweeter.
He is an assistant professor
at the School of Management,
trained as a social psychology,
social personality
psychologist at Berkeley,
where he received his B.A.
in psychology and sociology
and PhD in social psychology.
Before arriving at Yale, he was a postdoc
at UC San Francisco and then
at University of Illinois.
His research can be found in
leading psychology journals
and has been featured in media outlets
like the New York Times,
New York Magazine,
The Wall Street Journal,
NPR, ABC World News.
Michael is active on Twitter
as you will soon learn
where he shares research news and comments
on politics and social inequality.
Fiona Scott Morton, next to
me, has been justly called
a rockstar for portraying
disciplined economic literacy
and concern for enforcement
in the consumer interest.
She was recently named a
radical by The New Republic.
(audience applauds)
(panelists laugh)
- Undeserved.
- She teaches economics at
the School of Management
where she's been on
the faculty since 1999.
Her area of research is
empirical industrial organization
with a focus on empirical studies
of competition in areas like pricing,
entry, and product differentiation.
Her public articles range widely
across industries from magazines
to shipping to pharmaceuticals
to internet retailing
and are published in
leading economic journals.
From 2011 to 2012, Professor Scott Morton
served as Deputy
Assistant Attorney General
for Economics in the Antitrust Division
of the U.S. Department of Justice,
where she helped enforce
the nation's antitrust laws.
Yale SOM, she teaches courses in the area
of competitive strategy
and many other honors.
And you can see a little bit of her
most recent Tweets here.
And finally, Jason Stanley
knows the world is on fire,
but he can laugh about it.
He's the Jacob Urowsky
Professor of Philosophy
at Yale University, the
author of five books,
most recently How Fascism Works,
the winner of the 2007 Academic
Philosophical Association
Book Prize for his 2005 book,
Knowledge and Practical Interests.
He writes on propaganda, authoritarianism,
mass incarceration, free
speech, and other issues
for the Times, Boston
Review, Washington Post,
Chronicle of Higher Ed,
and other publications.
He serves on the Board of
Prison Policy Initiative.
Now before we get into
our serious discussion
of Twitter and all that it can do
for professors in their serious lives,
we know what, how things
can end up often going.
So I'd like to start by
asking each of the panelists
how they started on Twitter
and how they use it now.
Fiona?
- Okay, sure.
I joined Twitter because Steve
Berry guilted me into it.
He said people were asking
where are all the IO economists
on Twitter, there don't seem to be any,
and that was true, there really weren't.
So I joined, and I use it really entirely
as a work platform, I don't
do anything social in Twitter.
Well occasionally, someone
in my group will say,
you know, I got a journal article
or here's the bar cart, we're
having a happy hour, whatever.
But that's pretty infrequent.
Mostly I use it as a work platform,
both to comment on the
economics of policy,
mostly antitrust enforcement or healthcare
kind of policy choices
made by the government.
And then also, I feel that it's a way
to keep in touch with former students
who were interested in
the material in my class
and which is related to current events,
and I can keep telling them about how
that class material
relates to current events.
So that's really how I use it,
and I find it to be
really great in that way.
I think I, because of
using it as a work vehicle,
I don't have much of the
snarky piling on stuff
that seems to happen in the rest Twitter
and I only follow about 50 people,
most of whom don't tweet very much,
so that I'm getting just the events
in my field coming into my feed.
- [Emily] Thank you, Joanne?
- I am having a very different
Twitter experience from you.
(both laugh)
I first got on Twitter
pretty much against my will.
I'm low tech, slow tech, and
I wasn't even on Facebook.
And I did, I don't know if any of you
have heard of the OpED Project,
but it's a great a project
that's getting women
and people of color out into the world,
being public commentators
and writing op-eds,
so I did that here at
Yale, and they insisted
that everyone who's in the program
have a social media
presence, and in the session
that we were in, in the class,
they said, right now, you're
all gonna sign up for Twitter
while you're sitting right here
and you're gonna tweet
something, which I did,
and then basically didn't
really know what to do with it.
I got a sense of what it could do
during the last presidential election.
I think before that, I
was probably tweeting out
occasional interesting
historical things I found,
new databases that I thought
colleagues would like,
interesting pieces of historical
evidence that I found,
but during the election I guess there was
a particularly strident
attack against the judiciary,
and I went on Twitter
and I even apologized,
I said, I know we all know this,
but I feel the need to talk
about checks and balances,
the balance of power, and
why the separation of powers
is important in this country,
so that you understand
why attacking the
judiciary is a bad thing.
And I didn't, I guess I sort of assumed,
I apologized 'cause I thought
a lot of my colleagues
would be looking at it, but
I was going insane with,
anyway, I sent that out there,
and I got this stream of,
huge response from the public,
saying, thank you for
explaining that to us.
And it dawned on me, number one,
people didn't necessarily know that,
and number two, what an
incredible teaching tool.
Right, in that moment,
that something important was communicated,
who knows how many people.
But so, I use it for a
variety of different ways,
I keep in touch with colleagues,
I stay on top of news and
also things about my field,
but I feel really aggressively
that I speak to the public about history,
about the government, I
use a lot of documents
so I'm not screaming,
actually very deliberately
I'm not screaming, I'm very low key,
and I try to not allow
emotion to be on there at all.
This morning I woke up and I said,
good morning, I'm gonna send out
the Presidential Oath of
Office for people to see,
here you go,
and I didn't say anything
more than that really.
I then connected things to
it and said more than that,
but at any rate.
It's an incredible teaching
tool, that's my main takeaway.
- [Emily] I think you told
me your second follower
or your first follower
was Lin Manuel Miranda.
- My second, yeah, so yeah.
So the one thing I did on Twitter
was I knew two people on
Twitter, I knew my friend
and my friend who had told
me that he was on Twitter.
And so when I joined it
and made my one tweet
and then I went to find my friend,
and then I thought the
only other person I know
who's on here is Lin Manuel Miranda,
and he happened to make
an Alexander Hamilton joke
right when I beamed in, and I responded.
And he was like, Joanne Freeman?
(audience laughs)
And then suddenly I was like
whoa, there are these people,
there's a conversation,
so yeah.
- [Emily] Very cool.
Teresa.
- So I first joined
Twitter as a post-doctoral
research fellow when I was just graduated
from public health and I wanted to connect
with the social
entrepreneurship community.
I was in a university that's very siloed
in terms of discipline and
the different graduate schools
don't really talk to each other,
and social entrepreneurship
isn't really, or at least
at the time wasn't really
an academic discipline,
it's people who have studied public policy
or public health or management
and they're all working
in this innovative, cross-cutting area.
And so that's what I was
using Twitter for mostly,
to find out who the key stakeholders are,
what different people were doing,
and to just get involved
in the conversation.
So I started following institutions
that support social entrepreneurs
and people out there doing what I thought
were amazing, daring, bold things,
and just learning about what's going on
and how are people doing
things differently,
'cause I had a very
mainstream academic upbringing
and I just wanted to
kind of break the silos.
So that's really what it means to me,
it's about breaking silos,
extending beyond your academic
discipline, and creating,
if not new disciplines then
just new ways of doing things,
talking to the unusual suspects
and hearing different voices and opinions.
And I also use it a lot
to bridge my two worlds,
because I come from Lebanon
and I spend a lot of time there
and my grassroots work is there.
For a while, I was running the Twitter
and all the social media
of my organization,
Alfanar, which means Lighthouse in Arabic.
It's a venture philanthropy organization.
So I learned about comms
and social media at the time
'cause I had to become
savvy about what works
and what doesn't and when do
people see their Twitter feed
and how you should always have a photo
and those types of things
that I had no idea about,
'cause I'm trained as a
number cruncher basically.
And so, so yeah, I learned to enjoy it,
and then when I created a textbook
based on my course on
social entrepreneurship,
I realized it's a good way to share it
and hear what people think
and that's when I learned
that it's a great way to
build a new community,
because I started getting tweets
from people who would say
oh, I'm on the second page
of this book and I know
I'll use it in my course,
and I was like, wow, that's incredible.
And then I reached out to that person
and we Skyped and we became friends
and we met up at a conference
and then I helped her
get into a fellowship and she
helped me think through things
and so now she's one of my closest friends
and colleagues just from a tweet.
So those kinds of of things, I feel that,
you know, there can be magic
that happens on Twitter.
So I'm not a frequent user,
I mostly just create lists,
like when I came to Yale,
I created a Yale list
that I try to check as often as I can.
I think it's a great way
to connect with people.
- [Emily] Michael.
- So I guess I've been on
Twitter for more than 10 years,
and then I was a graduate
student when I started,
so you can imagine if you think
you have something to say,
there's not necessarily
people who are interested
in what you're saying at that time.
So I think early on,
Twitter was more of a way
to curate news for me,
so I was reading it,
understanding it, if there,
there weren't a lot of people
in anybody's field on Twitter early on,
so the platform kind of grew
into a place where you could,
like what some of the other
people here are saying,
like connect to people in your field,
be updated on current events,
be updated on current studies
in your field, and then sort of,
you know, over the course of your career,
people start listening to you,
and so my use of the platform
sort of starts to change
to be more of what, what am
I gonna say in this space?
There's a lot of discourse,
how can you use your science
and your research and your scholarship
to inform that discourse?
So it's taken on more of
that, although it's still,
for me at least, dad jokes as well.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
- [Emily] Jason.
- So I'm one of the few
humanists on Twitter
who's not a historian.
So historians are sort
of making their mark
with Joanne and Kevin Krauss and others.
I avoided Twitter, I was a Facebook person
and I had this Facebook account
that had all the editors
of the major newspapers
and magazines on it, and
that's where I did my work
and shared pictures of my kids.
And then I had a Facebook post that,
it was a private Facebook post,
but the right wing somehow screenshot it
and there was like 20 articles
in the right wing press
and I got all this hate
stuff and I started realizing
I probably shouldn't have a page
that has pictures of my family.
And so I deleted my Facebook account,
this was in fall 2016, and then,
and I wanted a platform
that it would force me
never to do anything
personal (laughs) on it,
because everyone, my eight year old says,
Daddy, everyone can see Twitter.
So unlike Facebook where actually,
you are being watched because
there's gonna be people,
like, in the middle of that firestorm,
I had someone contact me
from a security agency,
and they said take your
Facebook page down immediately,
and I said why, he said right now,
every comment and post
for the last nine years
is being screenshot for
future articles about you.
And so, I was, oh, that's
an excellent reason.
(audience laughs)
So Twitter gives me an opportunity
to do my antifascist work but
without revealing where I am,
without revealing any
person details of my life,
and I don't have any social
media that does that.
- So since Twitter is visible by everyone,
how do you feel about interacting
with the general public?
Do you, and what's your approach
to them, do you feel like
you're using it as a
teaching tool generally?
Joanne, you mentioned that, and Teresa,
you know, I've seen everyone,
almost everyone here
interact with friends, colleagues,
people they know kind of personally,
how do you code-switch from speaking
to just a small group
of people to everyone?
- Well, there's two flavors of Twitter.
I mean, it's still just as public,
but I think one of the ways
in which you can communicate
the message that you send when you use it
is I'm not being as public, right?
So you can send something
out to the entire world
or you can just respond to one person.
Now, everyone can look at the thing
you send to that one person,
but it's not beamed out
automatically everywhere.
So that's a little bit of code-switching.
I think it's really easy to forget
and underestimate the degree to which,
like your kid said, people
really see everything.
And there have been moments, this morning.
This morning, George Conway,
Kellyanne Conway's husband,
said something about the ABC interview
yesterday with the
president in which he said
he would take information
and maybe go to the FBI.
And Conway said, the
president just said he might
take information, foreign information.
And I said, no, it's not a
maybe, which he then retweeted.
And I don't know what's
happening right now on Twitter.
(audience laughs)
- [Teresa] Let's check.
- I know.
Anyway, so I just replied to him,
but he retweeted it and
now I don't, stuff's--
- I mean, I think the problem
with platforms like this
is you can't code-switch, there's nothing,
you have one message,
it goes to everybody,
and you have to think
very carefully about how,
I spend a long time
composing my Twitter messages
because they have to be
read, the tone of voice
has to be exactly right, read
by anybody from any background
with any language in any mood--
- For accuracy, right?
- At any time of day.
- 'Cause we're academic.
- Because it's gonna be
quoted back to me one day,
so I have deleted, I have
composed and not sent
many Twitter messages, it's just not safe.
So it's, my own personal conversation
is way more lively than my Twitter feed,
but you can't do that,
that's really not wise.
- If you think about what George--
some of the academics
who've been taken down
by the right for their tweets,
they're clearly, like take
George Ciccariello-Maher.
His tweet was "All I wanted for--
"All I want for Christmas
is white genocide."
It's clearly sarcastic,
it's clearly making a joke
that there's no white genocide.
I mean, I talked to him after that,
he gets like 24/7 intense harassment,
the president of his
university denounced him
for a clearly sarcastic tweet.
So sarcasm doesn't, you
know, they will take it
completely out of context
and it's totally irrelevant
what you say afterwards.
So you need to be very clear that like,
I try to be very earnest on Twitter.
- And as an academic,
you also have to think
not just tone, but factually.
And I guess this particularly
true for me as a historian.
If I wanna say, you know, if you asked
the Founders this, they
probably would have said that,
again, that's within the
last day or two I did that,
and then I went back and I said,
I was gonna say they would have said,
and then I said no, many
of them would have--
- Probably would have.
- Right.
Because they all wouldn't have said it,
and somebody would come back at me
and then there'd be a conversation,
so you do have to think about every word,
you really have to think about your tone.
I would say everyday,
I write and undo tweets
that make perfect sense to me
and I wish I could say them,
and then it's just not smart.
- [Fiona] Correct.
- And notoriously, Twitter
does not have an edit button,
and that can be good in a way,
because people can't do things over,
they have to delete and rewrite.
Michael, you've written a lot
about racial inequality gaps,
and what, do you get a
lot of online harassment,
do you get people who are attacking you?
- Yes, so I mean, I guess, the thing
that sort of motivates a
lot of what I write about
on Twitter and my tone is like,
so I guess maybe the strongest motivation
is to be truthful and to be factual,
so I spend a lot of
time just thinking like,
what's the truth here, and
that's what motivates what I say.
I think that there's a little
bit of a difference in scale
to where, my harassment's not gonna rise
to the level of other people
because I just don't have
the magnitude of microphone.
So it's not as intense.
- [Emily] Have you blocked people?
- Sure, yeah, it's healthy to do that.
(panelists laugh)
Yeah.
So I mean, it's just something you monitor
and you're trying to be careful
but you're also trying to be truthful,
and I think that's, and
you're trying to be yourself
in ways that it's allowed on the platform,
at least that's how I use it.
- But also, you know, you're tweeting
because you wanna communicate something,
and sometimes it's just to a colleague
or getting out information, but sometimes,
it's because people need to understand
checks and balances,
right, I mean, to teach.
And again, you don't know how
many people are reading it,
(air conditioner comes on)
but wow, that's dramatic,
but again, I guess I talked
about it as a teaching tool.
It's a remarkably powerful teaching tool.
- [Fiona] Yeah, thousands of people.
- Tens of thousands of people,
and I've been on a book tour
in the fall, that whole semester,
and everywhere I went
where people who knew me
from Twitter, commented about
things I'd said on Twitter,
young women who liked seeing
a woman say things in public.
There were all kinds of ways
in which it just didn't dawn
on me, the impact of
what you do on Twitter.
- That's interesting.
So I sense that, do
you find it empowering?
Do you feel like you're
using your teaching voice,
your kind of nonprofit organizing voice,
both, your personal voice?
- I actually have a lot
of anxiety about tweeting.
I think that, well, there
are two different ends
where I try to modify my voice.
One end in when I'm being too technical
and I get feedback from
people not in my field like,
we have no idea what you're saying,
you're talking to like 10 people.
So I try to explain more
and use more outward-facing language.
The other end is when there's something
that I really care about
and a lot of people
also really care about it,
and it's such a contentious,
divisive topic and there's
a huge social injustice,
and on the one hand, you
want to say something,
and on the other hand, you're just like,
no, that's not what my platform is for,
you know, people are
already commenting on this
and I don't wanna get sucked into that,
and what if what I say is misinterpreted,
so yeah, I'm really
cautious about tweeting,
especially from the part
of the world that I'm from,
there's just so many (laughs), yeah.
- Can you say more about that?
- I mean for example,
there was one professor
that I heard about who
commented on comments,
on events happening in the Middle East
and got fired, basically, because it was--
- The Middle East is--
- He was too emotional,
and so people interpreted
as like hate speech,
even though he felt he was--
- Steven Salaita.
- Yeah, maybe.
- [Jason] At the University
of Illinois or wherever,
who now drives a bus.
- Right, a colleague of mine--
- A school bus.
- From SOM Forward News article,
and I think he just
felt that he was talking
about an injustice and you know,
he felt really passionately
that this was wrong,
and then it got interpreted as
hate speech and he got fired.
So there's a fine balance
between speaking up
and not being heard in
the most productive way.
- There's a way to
communicate, so recent--
without being, I've been working on trying
to communicate information without it
being possible for it to be an article
in the Washington Times or Breitbart.
So for instance, Jared
Kushner recently had
this interview with Axios, and I noticed
that he was just parroting lines
from Frank Luntz's 2009
Israel Project report.
So what I did was I tweeted
the Frank Luntz's Israel Project report
and a quote from it that Kushner said
and then it linked it to Kushner's,
so then nobody could take that
it just said look, he
just tweeted a 100-page
document and quoted this part,
well that sounds familiar.
So there are ways to
communicate information
without it being a headline.
'Cause some, like Salaita, the
tweet that he got fired for,
they couldn't fire, he
had moved from a non--
from a tenure track,
from a tenured position
to another position, but
the deans hadn't yet--
- They were trying--
- Approved his tenure.
And so he tweeted "Netanyahu looks like
"he's wearing teeth of
Palestinian children,"
but Salaita is Palestinian, so you know.
And so yeah, so it's very important,
like any short line can be, and yeah.
- [Joanne] Allowing other people
to say what you wanna say.
- Allowing other people
- That's a very useful tip.
- That's very useful.
- That's a great point.
- Yeah.
- And it has a kind of academic
citation quality as well.
- [Jason] Exactly.
- And you take just link
to it and just retweet it.
- Well, importantly, you frame it.
Here is someone who works
for Qualcomm saying this.
Here is somebody who's
supposed to be enforcing
the antitrust laws to protect consumers,
and they're saying this.
Right, and neither part
of that is controversial.
It's factual what their job is,
and it's factual what they said,
but most of the people, the
person who wrote the article
you're linking to is not
framing the way I'm framing it,
and so it makes, the reader then sees it
in a different way and realizes
oh, there's a problem here.
- And the same thing with saying,
yesterday I think I said,
here's the emoluments clause
of the Constitution, here's a
link to the National Archives
so you can see the
Constitution, that's all I said.
This is what it means, right?
So I didn't say anything.
- [Teresa] So you're planting the seed.
- Right, it's like
you're kind of wondering
what this is and why people
are talking about it,
hey, here's the actual text.
- Right.
- So with you know, there are
authoritarian governments,
there are actual censors around the world,
then there's kind of one's own self-censor
who some of you have referred to,
and we have a variety of
states of tenure in our panel.
(Jason laughs)
From any of your various institutions,
have you felt pressure
to tweet or not tweet
or to be a little bit more
judicious about what you say?
- I mean, alright, so I'll just say
I think Yale is a really
famous university,
and anybody who has a job here
is sufficiently good
that their own reputation
is something that they care a lot about
and can do lots of things with,
whether at Yale or another
place anywhere around the world.
So for me, it's not about
what the university wants,
it's about what my mission is,
which I believe is totally consistent
with the university's mission,
but I'm not thinking about
it as a Yale problem,
I'm thinking about it
as a making the world
a better place problem and allowing me
to be effective in doing
that for as long as possible,
which means I need to stay relevant
and truthful and direct and
all those other good things.
So I don't think there's a conflict,
and I think maybe if you were
asked at a different place,
you would get a different answer,
but I think, I mean everybody
here is super eminent
and is probably thinking the same way,
but I'll let you all
answer for yourselves.
- Well no, the question, you know,
that I ask myself with every tweet
is like, how is this gonna hurt me, right?
Is this gonna really smack me in the face?
That's equivalent to, what does it mean
that I'm a Yale professor tweeting this?
So it's, you can't particularly
at an institution like Yale,
you can't separate your identity
from the fact that that's who you are.
- Well, I never really
thought about it in that way
because I mostly, I like to
use Twitter as a connector.
This is just one of my hobbies
and my passions in life,
I love to connect people,
and so when I tweet,
it's mostly tweeting work
that other people have done
or work that I've done,
like check out this paper,
or oh, great job on this paper,
or look what this organization
has just achieved.
So it's nothing really that I feel
I would be held accountable for
or that I'm representing
Yale or anything like that.
I think that a university like Yale
gives you a platform to better
and more strongly connect people,
and Twitter is one channel
through which you can do that.
- Yeah, so I just, one of the ways
that you can think about your relationship
to your employer on Twitter is like,
well I better watch what I say,
but another one is the
reach of your scholarship
is much greater to the extent
that you're engaging with it.
So you know, papers that
I haven't tweeted about,
my mom has read them, and
then papers that I have,
you know, thousands of people will engage
in some form with it, be it
like a pull quote from it
or graphs from it, right, so,
I think it goes both ways.
You have to think about
what this looks like
as a professor at this institution,
but it's also, you're communicating,
connecting to your field in ways
that you know, gets you invited to talks
because people heard about your work
because they saw you
write about it on Twitter,
and these are people who you
know, again, in our field,
a lot of its reputation based,
they're gonna be writing,
if we're gonna get really career about it,
they're gonna be writing
tenure letters and the like,
so as someone untenured,
I think it cuts both ways
and it's important to
think about that too.
- I prefer Twitter because on Facebook
I did embarrass Yale a little
bit by, there were, so,
the incident that I got involved with was
a philosophy professor David Koch
arguing that homosexuality
is a disability,
and I used some potty language
in describing the talk.
(audience laughs)
So, some potty words, so
no potty words on Twitter.
(panelists laugh)
But generally, I think my, you know,
I have the luxury of being tenured,
but I've tried just to
speak my mind my whole life,
and if Yale's gonna fire me for that,
Yale's gonna fire me for that.
- So those are some of the
stickier moments of Twitter.
What's the most fun for you?
Where do you, I know, you know,
Michael, I know you do
tweet about your family,
about sports and other fun things.
Is that, does that take
you down a rabbit hole
or is that a good rabbit hole?
- (laughs) No, I mean, all of it's fine,
everything's fine, everything's fine.
(panelists laugh)
- He said nervously.
- No, what I would say is that
when I think about what
I'm like on Twitter,
I think about who's watching,
and a lot of the people
who watch and follow and
engage with me on Twitter
are graduate students, right,
they're undergraduates,
they're recent graduates of our program,
our MBA program, and so if I can be my,
more of my full self in public,
it invites more and
different kinds of people
to also be themselves in academic spaces.
One of the things I really care about
is having a more equitable university,
and I think it's a value that Yale shares.
We don't always uphold that value,
and so one of the barriers
to it is that you know,
academics kind of all tend
to look a certain way,
but if you allow for more difference,
you communicate that normatively,
you can actually create changes and norms,
so I think that that
too, so the two months
during the NBA playoffs
when my Twitter feed
is just Warriors gifs,
(Jason laughs)
part of that is because I
really like basketball a lot,
but also, a part of
it's being a full person
in a visible space that allows
other people to see that.
- I have a goofy example of that.
- Please.
- Trivial yet funny.
So there's a, and it's actually an example
of things that Twitter can
do that you don't imagine.
So there's a bunch of historians who,
we used to do it Sunday
night, and now I think
it's Saturday night or
moving back to Sunday night,
but at nine o'clock at night,
this community of historians
goes on Twitter and watches
a historical movie together
and live-tweets a response
to what we're seeing.
It's actually, if you're interested,
it's hashtag H-A-T-M,
Historians at the Movies.
So very early on, and now
the public is in there too
and it's become much bigger.
So very early on in the process,
I somehow mentioned that I'd
never seen National Treasure,
so then that became
the movie we looked at,
and I was screaming in outrage,
you know, and they put lemon juice
on the Declaration of Independence, right?
(audience laughs)
But the writers of National Treasure
saw this and beamed in.
- Oh cool.
- So then it was
historians commenting on it
and the writers commenting on it,
and I literally did
say, you put lemon juice
on the Declaration of Independence!
(panelists laugh)
And the writers were like,
we didn't realize it would seem
like that big a deal
to historians (laughs).
So that was just fun, but
that's such a Twitter moment,
when suddenly you're like wait,
I'm talking to the writers?
And they're listening to historians?
Like how interesting is that?
- So I only use Twitter for work,
but there's different kinds of work,
and I think the most fun I had
was when we were running
a Kickstarter campaign
with my organization to support
a bunch of refugee women that
we're trying to crowdfund
for a food truck to help
scale their catering company.
So it's a really random pitch,
and so far, we had only
had about a hundred
high net worth individuals
that were in our close circle
financing all these
ventures, and when we did
the Kickstarter campaign,
we got 800 individuals
from around the world from countries
that these women had never heard of
and that they would have never dreamed
that these people had heard of them,
and so Twitter was a huge part of that
because we were really systematic
about when to tweet and who to tweet to,
and we got Susan Sarandon to tweet it,
and you know, celebrities
and random things like that,
so it was so much fun,
and it was also exhausting
'cause it lasted for two months
and you worry that people get
fatigued from your campaign.
But we had an awesome
time and it got funded,
and it was just the most
incredible experience ever.
- Joanne, I know you've
talked about engaging
with people with, especially
with Founding Fathers fans,
you had a real, grab bag of people.
- Yes (laughs).
- Am I characterizing that--
- There is a grab bag of people, yes.
- And so all of you I imagine
have engaged with people who,
I mean, there's a teaching tool
for people like your
students and people who,
you know, are fact based and
so forth, and then there are
people who are violently
opposed to your ideas,
what is it, Jason for instance,
what is that like when
people, when you're trying,
do engage and try to teach
people who don't agree with you?
- I don't engage generally
with the people who,
I get a lot of sort of
international tweets,
I mean, tweets in Portuguese
'cause I'm doing stuff
in different countries,
but, that are to be--
I mean, Brazil seems to have sort of,
from what I recognized,
somewhat violent culture
directed among their far right.
But I always engage extremely
civilly, I always just,
if I engage, it's always respectfully
and civilly on Twitter.
I mean Facebook I think was dangerous
because it gave you this
illusion of privacy,
and Twitter, I just try to model,
unfortunately I come from a
very combative profession,
analytic philosophy, where the only form
of a question is you're
wrong because dot, dot, dot.
(panelists laugh)
So we're all used to,
and we're all used to odd views,
like I had a former colleague,
I have a colleague here at Yale
who believes there's only one thing,
so you know, I'm used to strange views--
- Economists are like that too.
- I'm used to combative discourse.
So I only engage civilly and respectfully,
even with, you know, neo-Nazis.
- So I would say that one big decision
that you make when you're on Twitter
is which people to respond to.
- Right.
- So there are plenty of
people who disagree with me
and write something that
I don't even understand,
or they write something
that's totally ignorant
and uninformed, and you think,
I could teach them, but
they're not paying tuition,
so that would be a long, complex process,
I probably wouldn't succeed,
and it would take a lot of time
and I don't even know who they are.
So the people that I tend to respond to
and try to teach are the
ones who have a name,
somebody who is actually
another faculty member
at another university or is a reporter
of some stature or whatever--
- And a picture usually too, right?
- So it's not anonymous, they're
in it with their reputation
as well, and then, and
I'm doing the civil thing,
explaining, here's why,
but I think if you try
to respond to people, there's a danger
that you go down into the
mud pit if you respond
to people who are not
operating at that same level.
And so I try to avoid
responding to people,
sort of will make a very
provocative tweet in response
and obviously trying to get me to engage,
and I feel like engagement
is itself an endorsement,
and I am not going to
endorse people who are not
on the debate in the same terms that I am.
- Yeah, the screenshot, the provocative,
the trying to get you to respond angrily
and get a screenshot of that,
I've had like fake articles
done of like, provocative
responses that I did.
You know, people provoking me
and then me saying something
and then they'll put a
different context around it.
So you have to be aware when
you're on those platforms
what people try to do to get you
to respond in an uncivil way.
- But you know occasionally,
and I do exactly what you do,
which is, if someone insults
me, I'm not gonna respond.
If someone is screaming or doesn't,
there's a whole category
of people like that
that I would not respond to.
But I have had people contact me
who are angry about something I've said,
aren't insulting me,
aren't venting anger at me
but clearly think differently than I do
and I clearly think, well
if you knew this thing--
- Right, it would help a lot.
- You might think differently.
And I have responded to those people,
and I have to confess, it
happened more two years ago
than it happens now, but more than once,
someone would say, well you don't know
what you're talking about
because blah, blah, blah,
and I would say well, and I would erase
all emotion from my response,
and I would say well--
- Have you read this?
- It's interesting that you say that,
but I actually think this and this is why.
And more than once, I had
someone who clearly didn't agree
with me politically respond by going,
huh, I'm gonna think about that.
And you know, it's one person--
- Makes you feel good.
- But right,
it's like there was a moment
of communication there
that you know, at least
in my understanding
of the current ethos, it's nice to know
that you can have that moment.
And again, it reconfirms the fact
that the teaching potential of Twitter
used in a savvy kind of a way is powerful.
- And also, you don't win
an argument by showing great emotion.
You win an argument by remaining calm.
Like, when I was a junior faculty member,
someone said, you know, you
celebrate in the end zone
before you've won the
game too much in talks,
when I see that I'm gonna win.
(panelists laugh)
Celebrating in the end zone
takes away from your point.
- It's interesting because I know there's,
I've seen an argument a lot on Twitter
that especially women, people of color,
and other marginalized
groups are not responsible
for teaching or they should be compensated
in some way for teaching,
but you're all teachers.
So how does that, does it sort of,
does that trump the sort of sense of like,
well, I'm not here for your education.
But it sounds like kind of are.
- No, of course we are.
- Yeah.
- We're teachers, that gets the mission.
And if we can reach, you know,
the number of people I can
teach in the classroom is small,
but if I can teach thousands of people
on the internet, that's fantastic.
- And current students follow,
former students follow,
so that's also, it's continuing,
and you can see them
engaging further with ideas,
so yeah, I think, I mean,
that's the main reason
I think I'm there.
- I agree.
- Michael, you would agree with that?
- Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, with everything
that's said, yeah (laughs).
- So I know we're running,
maybe you have time
for one or two questions?
Yes.
- [Questioner 1] Relatively recently,
a transgender woman in academic philosophy
wrote about her experience
of being driven out
of the field because of discrimination.
She posted on Twitter, she said what,
basically, existing online is precarious,
but that precarity is not
distributed equitably.
The second professional
interactions take place on Twitter,
it creates sort of a boys club.
- So this is my field,
my field is notorious
for its viciousness, for
its patriarchal sentiment,
for its, and many of the senior men
in my profession have decided
suddenly they're feminists
because now there's this movement of,
I wanna be careful about what I say,
but now there's this movement
of gender critical feminists
who are argue that transgender
women aren't really women,
and so suddenly, there's all these people
who I remember as having hated feminism,
suddenly they're like, I'm a feminist,
because I'm, you know.
So yeah, so there's very,
academic philosophy has often had
a very vicious, part of
it is our general culture,
and we're, you know,
I've tangled with the
forces you've mentioned.
And it, you know, you can't
really call it a boys club
because you have that
U.K. group of feminists,
and you know, they are feminists
and I respect their views, but
they're definitely championed
by the senior men in philosophy,
and so it's been a bad situation.
It's so intense that, I
mean, I tweet about trans--
I mean I write about transgender issues,
I've written about it in my book,
because all over the world,
these far-right movements,
neo-fascist movements
attack transgender women.
You know, turning boys
into girls, is like,
so I'm like, well, I'm fine for people
to have discussions about gender,
but how do you negotiate this fact?
- I think you're asking a
really interesting question,
which is that, is this a platform
to reduce inequalities and disparities,
or does it actually promote and exacerbate
existing inequalities and disparities?
And I'd love to hear what others think.
- So for economics, it reduces them.
I mean, I can't be interrupted
on Twitter, for example.
(panelists laugh)
I just, I tweet.
So I would say there's no boys club,
I don't perceive any kind of boys club,
I don't perceive any kind of
issue in the economics debate.
- But I do, I do think
related to your question,
people with privilege of various sorts
have louder voices
because they can, right?
And they're not as vulnerable.
And Twitter does do that.
But you know, what that
then means to me is,
okay, I'm a tenured
professor, I teach at Yale,
I can get out there and
say something, right,
I can say something that
I feel needs to be said
and I have that privilege
and I can use that privilege.
So I wouldn't say it's a boys club,
but I feel it's important
to have a loud female voice.
And you know, the fact that other women,
women graduate students,
high school girls,
have responded that way
made me think about that
in a way that I hadn't thought about it.
- Well in philosophy I should say,
there are very vocal women feminists
attacking transgender women,
so it's a very bad situation,
and I do not weigh in on
it, because whenever a male
weighs in on it, they're
accused of being a misogynist.
So if I would say, I stand up,
so it's a very particular situation,
and you know, 100% of the--
yeah, it's, but it has to
do with this privilege,
you know, it's a common reaction.
- I think one more quick question
and then we have to wrap up.
Please, yes.
- [Questioner 2] So Twitter tends to form
these micro communities,
like if you were looking
as an economist, you might
be in the economy Twitter,
there's philosophy Twitter.
But after making an effort,
especially after you get used to it,
engage with people outside
of your specific discipline.
Like I feel that that's
Twitter's wonderful opportunity
platform for--
- So I'll go first 'cause
I'm short, I don't,
that's not why I'm on Twitter.
I'm on Twitter to talk about antitrust
and healthcare policy to people
who are interested in that,
and if they're interested in me,
that's fine, but I'm not
trying to reach out to anybody.
- I guess I'll be the opposite,
'cause that's the whole point that,
that's the whole reason
that I'm on Twitter,
is to engage with, well I wanna engage
with people within public health
and also outside public health.
Like now I'm in a management school,
and I wanna get people who so far
are not interested in
social entrepreneurship
or social impact broadly speaking
to be interested in that.
And you have to use certain hashtags,
but yeah, I think that it's true,
you can go down into a vortex
and get even more specific,
or you can really create
a snowball effect,
it could go either way.
- I avoid, I mean, a lot of my life
has been trying to avoid
the ugliness of my field,
and I'm very happy to be involved
in a larger political discourse
outside of the gossip about my profession.
- Whereas for me, a big part of my sense
of being a historian is public history,
'cause a historian should
be talking to the public.
I give public lectures,
I co-host a podcast,
I do this in a lot of ways,
and what I now understand
is that Twitter is another way to do that,
and a powerful one.
Might not be recognized that way yet,
but I think, to me, kind of
like what Teresa was saying,
that's the point of it,
is to not just talk to my colleagues,
although I love talking to them,
but it really is to reach out.
- It's hard to do philosophy,
a philosophical argument,
in 280 characters.
(panelists laugh)
You ever read the Critique of Pure Reason?
- Oh well, Michael, do you
want the last word on that?
- No, I'm good.
- Okay.
(panelists laugh)
Well here is everyone
that you see before you.
I hope you'll follow everybody.
Everyone's immensely
edifying and entertaining,
and it's a treat to be, to
know you all on Twitter,
and in some cases, to know you in person,
so thank you very much.
- Thank you Emily.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(gentle instrumental music)